greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now was brought to
you by the zip recruiter listen a fresh
new year has begun and if you're setting
new goals for your business it's
extremely difficult to reach them
without the right people on your team
zip recruiter has transformed how you go
about finding them
does it preclude approach your job to
over a hundred of the web's leading job
boards with just one click find out
today why the zip recruiter has been
used by businesses of all sizes and
industries to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results
and right now today the church family
can post jobs on zip recruiter for free
that's right free free free just go to
zip recruited on slash church that zip
recruiter Dodge crew know that zip
recruiter dot-com slash church one more
time I messed that one up that zip
recruiter comm slash Church get the best
talent available to you right now number
two you know what you're number two new
year resolutions should be I'm gonna
wash my ass more this year I'm gonna
have my ass tip top Magoo four times a
day because from time to time I put my
hand down there and I'm scared to waive
it cuz flopping birds will come down and
I'm saying that's why you got hello to
she go - hello - she calm and use code
church for 10% off your order why walk
around with a filthy [ __ ] [ __ ] and
nuts thinking like a dead man when you
can have a portable bird day right now
you could use it even if you don't [ __ ]
you sometimes just in the mood to wash
your balls you could dip your nutsack
into that but they turn that nice little
cold water on so come up with that new
water and that new soap that liquid soap
and sponging more like a [ __ ] loofah
you know what happens to your nuts tick
tock Magoo
you gotta pay people be paying you to
suck your [ __ ] nutsack
go - hello - she calm right now and
press in church for a 10% discount
60-day money-back guarantee hello Trish
you the best portable day out in the
market I also want to give a shout out
to my family on it always on it
with the best supplements out there you
understand me from half a brain - shroom
tech - the hem force protein shake Coco
that's my world go 200 common press
Church and get this party started
Lee kick this [ __ ] mule Church so
what's happening here happy new year
maybe this year better be your best year
on [ __ ] reckon you understand me
you'll be healthy because rally held you
got dick and with the health everything
else will fall into place
my guest tonight a [ __ ] D'Agostino Zoi
- my little brother and the
[ __ ] the original the matzo
listo they sigh at freshmen lugia
stripped San Jose beautiful - [ __ ]
savage you Sammy
you made San Jose a new New Year's shift
just follow me from Long Beach to San
Jose that and then top trips in
California do up there I did a lot of
stuff please oh my god there's a museum
there's a Computer History Museum that
was cool went out of the house where
Steve Jobs was grew up and started Apple
we went into a place in the Santa Cruz
called the Mystery Spot what it was
[ __ ] awesome oh yeah we went to Santa
Cruz they have a place in the redwood
forest where for whatever reason things
just aren't the same like compasses go
crazy you feel dizzy like I you like the
house like every building they try to
build on this hill falls and slides the
house oh you feel like you're like
really did they felt like you were had
what's the thing vertigo oh my god it
was cool anything and we wanted a tour
there what else did we do
yeah the Computer History Museum was
really cool it was just seeing the birth
of of computers a hundred years ago and
we like but actually taking us back to
like abacuses and like I didn't even
know computers started with a punch card
system like a like an actual paper card
was telling a computer what to do
there wasn't any memory or anything in
the computer it's what it was pretty
interesting and yeah it was uh
it's great up there it was we I had the
best sushi of my life up there it was
four with no valet parking and not
everyone's nice everyone everyone just
had like everyone had any stores happy
to see you
and it just it doesn't happen on
everywhere you go so we had a great time
up there very nice yeah oh yeah anyway
shout out to the bear you know the same
anyway I was your new used my friend
very very light I loved it
it's great you even think about going
that no I don't want to it's so weird
how your life changes from New Year's at
one point you can't think I'm not being
out of New Year's and at one point
you're like okay I'm well he was doing
dick like I was in bed of Ted I went to
Huntington Beach Johnny to [ __ ]
edibles and I had 7:30 I knew it was
gonna be oh it was gonna be a rough
night like I'm like I don't think I'll
make it to [ __ ] midnight I had them
on the beach we walked half the [ __ ]
beats looking for seashells
bend over once I'd have been over a
thousand times to pick up [ __ ] up
shells shark to do [ __ ] so I knew it was
gonna be you know walking in the sand
[ __ ] rush you up a little bit yeah so
we kept walking walking and walking dead
let's go chase the seagulls let's go do
this I look back at the [ __ ] bridge
I'm like one mile down dog that's a
[ __ ] walk yet and last night we're
gonna go to Dairy Queen was so [ __ ]
cold like I had dropped so much at that
point and we didn't want to walk with
her in the middle of [ __ ] circles of
people we just said [ __ ] it we stayed in
and watched I watched Shark Tank that
was my [ __ ] New Year's and I sat down
at one point like kind of depressed for
like 20 minutes because I was like what
the [ __ ] am i doing my life I'm gonna
Huntington Beach I'm in the hotel room
my wife and my daughter my wife told me
all three nights she's thinking oh
you're not gonna be you're gonna stay in
and all three nights I stayed at I was
only want to watch the fight Saturday
night and I was like why would I [ __ ]
want to go out there's a way to watch on
the computer I gotta just figure it out
I called Lee I got on YouTube but that
was very happy just sitting there
watching I was content it was the
perfect
like it was a vacation from the vacation
yeah which I don't really I don't want
to listen we got on a plane for a living
so if we take a vacation for me is going
to [ __ ] Hawaii on a six-hour flight
another six-hour hold that's not a
[ __ ] vacation for me that just
reminds me of [ __ ] work in Zion and I
think there's so many like leaves right
there's a lot of places in California
like I'd like to go to Joshua Tree but
she gets sick yeah I just thinking about
that I got sick on the way that I was
gonna ask you how she did it
listen to me we I don't do much with
mercy and my wife because we cannot
drive residences because for years there
was a [ __ ] puke fest yeah pull over
and change clothes and then again no
puke
it was just [ __ ] difficult we have to
take the calling it detailed just it was
just a disaster so we we've been working
in a lightly so Friday morning we get up
we get the [ __ ] car you know six
thirty seven thirty you know us man we
get up bang getting a [ __ ] car we
shoot down it I feel great
I had a protein shake I had been up for
an hour I was already packed and I went
to bed that night I was fine for some
reason my wife wasn't feeling well
she kept saying Joey if I die I'm
carsick would you believe me meanwhile
the whole time Mercy's saying nothing
John song came on and that she knows
from one of the [ __ ] movies yeah and
she was singing off the top I walked and
about 20 minutes out of out of uh
whatever Beach Island to meet us where I
finally broke down like it was just
horrible like the last 10-minute ride on
the 405 I don't know how I did it
Wow I kept drinking water had both
windows open I had the air on blast and
I can feel tingles all over my body
and finally we pulled over and dog I had
to puke right here my throat okay yeah
right there my throat and every
[ __ ] wanted to stop at a yellow
I was ready to go through a [ __ ]
truck with the [ __ ] car like no you
did not stop and a [ __ ] yellow light
though you did not stop at a [ __ ]
yellow light and finally I just pulled
into a street and guys let me tell how
bad my hair is at this point then when I
got out of the car my leg gave out and I
just turned around and laid on the car
for like five minutes
and then push myself back put my neck
down and just barked then I bar two like
two minutes
I [ __ ] wiped off my mouth with a
towel
I said wash my mouth out with water and
I opened up my Jack Antonoff and this
cold sweat came out of me oh I hate that
just this cold sweat came over my body
my wife came out of the car by that time
I was able to walk around the car and
sit in the passenger side and face the
street people were washing their cars
changing tires I'm sitting there sucking
them off and [ __ ] and I finally got back
to the whole town they did something I
told I gotta take a nap that's the
that's what balances me back it's like
an hour that whenever I get that cause
sickness yeah over for an hour like this
when I opened up four wheeler walker two
weeks ago three weeks ago when I got to
San Diego I'd take a bet
thank God I got the hotel thank God I
left early she's super carsick on a San
Diego yeah that's super duper but enough
yeah like when I got there I knew there
was gonna be a [ __ ] problem if I
don't get my life together so I'd take a
nap get up jump in the shower or eat
something I get really carsick - yes see
it's all right if I'm driving though I
remember I first started working with
you like first time we got in the car to
go to a gig to get somewhere together I
was just like oh I'll Drive I'll get
carsick if I don't and you're like guess
what me - [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] Drive I can't I can't
[ __ ] do it it's weird because you you
go on Laurel Canyon
four times a week and that's really
whiny yeah I get the foot balm okay for
the bottom okay I was kind of straight
and at that point so I'm I'm very
knocking one very lucky I never had to
deal with this so is it it doesn't have
anything to do with the wine D or just
driving has to do with everything I
guess for me I'm just feelin listen I
started out with it but then four years
and went away and then it just recently
came back in my old day
so you regress maybe I was a kid I
couldn't [ __ ] love a corner on a
bicycle I would get cause they're kind
of [ __ ] that bad I would get carsick
on the bottom but still going to Miami
one night and fishing and [ __ ] pass
it up and then trying to wake me up the
fish they caught they were cooking it
there was [ __ ] delicious that what
brought me back in fish they had to be
this fish it was breaking a little oh
forget that being like a seven year old
kid and eating the fish after I barf
everywhere on the deck and the Sunday
and back on the [ __ ] ship well your
daughter was good that's it could yes
she was perfect she was perfect why we
the ones that got sick but I'm telling
you it's still a fifty-fifty thoughts
bro yeah on the way this morning she had
breakfast a little bit of breakfast
never happened banana strawberry she
gets sick so I was happy about that you
know I was taken by you D'Agostino I
wanted even doing comedy for now it's
gonna be in February 9 years ago you
start in 2009 February 2009 like it's
weird I did today I bumped into somebody
at the park before I called you I was at
the park today but the baby and [ __ ]
and I bumped into a guy at the park that
he goes hey I don't our kids know each
other and we started talking about this
and they told me his wife had a podcast
and he was like uh the comic that never
made the jump you know we broke it down
with and we just sat there but he
watched the kids play and he goes can
you explain to me how you did it
you know at the beginning what made you
believe and I was like I went to New
York you know I was lost for two or
three years and comedy the first two or
three years I was really lost I was just
going to open mics I didn't have a plan
even though I had read a book or two and
had taken some comedy classes I'd take
on one class at that time but I didn't
really get the workload I was gonna get
what was ahead of me before I jumped
into it I thought he just got on stage
and got discovered as I said in this
podcast many times I didn't know what
that was work behind it that yeah you
could get discovered and you'll get put
somewhere and then you'll fail
because you didn't have the chops and
what was the sense of getting discovered
right so you know there's a kind of a
pattern the second process there's a
gate of a commitment level you know and
you when I got to Colorado in 93 I I
knew I was going to be a comic I knew I
was set to be a comic I never knew where
I'd be in LA and nothing like that I
just thought I'd be on the road
I told I'd be one of those comics that
just worked on the road you know I'm
saying that the success was working on
the road there was no TV credits there
was no film credits
it was just road work that's what I
thought I could accomplish you know so I
attacked it and at first I just attacked
him very wildly I will on Tribble runs
and then when I was home I just got on
every open mic so I did and there was
nothing really going on with it and then
by the time I got to Seattle in June of
95 was when I realized that I had to
treat this as I would treat a business
and it went right back to my car
salesman base I went back with my car
salesman days at the beginning of the
month were all zero me you and Lee on
the first of the month
we're all zero and it's how we worked a
month and now you start you start
learning a path of how to work thank God
I sold cars you could do to it okay so
I'll go to legally what do you need on
the 31st of January in the Agana 90
point 500 and I'll go what do you need
the agonist and I need 3,200 and what do
you need Joey I need 2800 and you sit
there and you analyze this you go how am
I gonna break this down in two weeks
because I'm the 15 there's a car
salesman you always gonna draw so you
could sit on your ass for those two
weeks you don't really have to do much
but what does that mean it draw a draw
they just give you 1500 after a while
you develop a trust with them and
they'll just give you 1500 hours and so
just taking your all your car deals and
everything
[ __ ] it we'll just give you 1500 and at
the end of the month we'll watch you out
mmm and I'm sure you'll make 1,500 plus
and then we'll give you the balance of
your money on the fifth of the month so
what you tend to do is get lazy as a
salesman you know you gotta check come
on the fifth cuz you got that 1500 or at
1500 on the 15th so you decide to go to
work at the second half of a month you
get strategic and even though I was on
coke and even though I was [ __ ] young
and stupid I always I looked at the guys
that were making money and I figured out
what they were doing they were very
strict about that time they're very
strict about their parents they were
very punctual they followed up
they had a pattern to follow up you know
how would going to work and just [ __ ]
pull out the deal sheets ahead and call
people or D'Agostino you still just in
that car come on them no these guys had
a notebook with a time when they called
them and what they said and notes and
when I started doing it that way that's
when I started last time we spoke you
look at the Volvo D'Agostino did you
pick up the wrong one so I took that
same plan like that was tool for car
sales and put it into comedy
and what the plan was basically was the
same thing what do we need to make your
nut every month there is Dana
now you life selling what new cars that
means you'll make 150 a car and [ __ ]
whatever you get back from the dealer so
the dealer has like who you call a
dealer after you sell the car and if
they give you $1 to $250 so your average
gonna be 150 to a hundred that's 250 a
car what was your number
it was 32 dirty Dan what's 8 what's to
15 to 30 to like 14 or somewhere yeah
you gotta sell 14 cars so how we gonna
[ __ ] sell 14 cars that's seven cars
per quarter first for you they're gonna
sell it all ops ops is freshly you'll do
50% of that business on
but they're gonna be people that you
spoke to the month will follow back with
ya
and that's why your numbers have to be
high your percentages have to be high so
you have to break it down into a
business just like that so what do I
need to sell three custards 14 cars
divided by four is [ __ ] off what
cause the [ __ ] week yeah so four
[ __ ] cars will we see your kids eat
so now what do you do you gotta be there
the whole time
that's gonna kill you what good isn't
having money if you don't have your
[ __ ] if you don't see your kids right
so your time becomes [ __ ] valuable so
I took all those elements from car sales
and I'm gonna put them in 10 it took me
four years but I finally go ha so what
did that mean that meant that I kept
records then I took a notebook and I
would put in January 1st that would put
ok this year would do 300 [ __ ] sets
because I was living in Boulder and in
bold I was doing 16 sets a month and I
had to drive all over God's creation I
had to do Tribble runs to get 16 sets a
month in Seattle I can get 20 cents a
month just staying in Seattle and
hustling you could do the three clubs
and guess that's under 20 [ __ ] sets
without doing anything so I figured to
get really good at Comley you need to do
300 sets a year you know what 300 sets a
year is that's 25 [ __ ] sets a month
that means if I go on the road all four
[ __ ] weeks
I'm only doing 20 [ __ ] sets I still
got to work out my days off but you
can't do that
so what do you do you count all these
little [ __ ] gigs of sets that's why
you do those preset nights because
you're like ooh I got that off my
[ __ ] back
and I'm saying even I always have goals
when I'm in town three sets a week I
don't want shout out every night but if
you do three sets a week and two podcast
I'm pretty [ __ ] happy if somebody
gives me two spots on a [ __ ] Tuesday
and I still got a Thursday and
sadly that I'm really [ __ ] happy I
picked up four do you guys get the urge
to like the does doing less spot and
make you want to do another one do you
like multiple spotlights absolutely
especially if you're chasing a goal if
your goal is you have set a different
type of gold what are you trying to do
it you're trying to be funny and get
comfortable on stage that means you have
to keep trucking going down there forget
about the funny let's just get
comfortable and learn how to set the mic
down and all that this is all baby steps
that people never really look at these
little things when it comes to comedy
but you could still do this you could
still apply these things whether you're
a computer tech or a plumber whatever
the [ __ ] you are you can still apply all
these same things that I did from the
car sales into the comedy room priests
to increase my comedy thing and then it
just really adored them me after about a
year economy I went towards Arianna
place
and what that guy that I've had him call
into the podcast for like the one year
we haven't call it on the first day of
the year to talk about gold and it was
the same saying now I go wait a second
how do I get funny how the [ __ ] already
gonna get funny so how do I get funny
and then you have to write like three
things under it get on stage write funny
material and [ __ ] you come up with a
third one and then every day go back to
it and rewrite it but that's how strict
my [ __ ] worth I could work ethic was
that McDonald II by the time I got the
Seattle I was making a living because I
put all the things in order what was a
living I don't make anything under a
month and I would have to drive to
Bremerton to [ __ ] if the coma [ __ ] like
that you know I'm saying but I still I'd
have to take a plane or drive long
distances the longest I would drive to
us for the tri-cities like
Spokane and all that out there they have
a comedy club out there now it's
okay I can't go cuz a warrant what we're
trying to get rid of the one we're
trying to get rid of the warrant in fact
they have a call Greg and which them
wish them a Happy New Year but I just
wanted to go what your goals are to
learn the amore yeah maybe to help you
out and help other comics so people
listen to the show just to go on the
u.s. plane you know and I was thinking
about you Friday then I went to dinner
with one of my young agents right how do
you know oh my god okay we were talking
we were talking about you your name came
up during the thing and I'm wait that's
really one that he asked me about the
Agostinho Neto saying like just set some
way you're really funny
I told that you were gonna write this I
didn't even want meant the Agostino
never quit you know you have your little
day game but you're always putting to
get a little hustles I try to give you
some work Shuba gives you some work this
guy gives you some more and that's what
you do this is the life of the comedy
this is where you're at right now and if
you freak out you're freaking out for no
reason because this is the life of the
comic like when I met Simone this is
when you you were Simone oh really
and now Simone headline last night at
the [ __ ] Minnesota the mall yeah he's
been working a lot is it Madison Square
Garden no it is but my point is that
this is the this is what you're looking
at now you have to sit down and alright
what do I want a composition I want oh
this yeah I want to do 30 more minutes I
want to do uh four spots of that a week
and I want to do I want to get into six
new clubs and maybe book a commercial
let's get really creative move the
commercial maybe in june i bump into a
commercial agent I'll take my headshot
and they say no I'm gonna [ __ ] tide
commercial with you [ __ ] Italians
jumping up and down
Wow where's my sweater yourself mom
where's my sweater and how do you like
if there's a comedian out there
listening how are how are you guys
realistic with where you are like with
your goals like if every one year
comedian is doing his girlfriend has it
going well this year I want a headline
you might say that they're not realistic
so no yeah you definitely should keep
realistic I mean I got
Nichole's I mean it's not like it's not
like I wouldn't want to have like a
[ __ ] special this year but I mean but
I know that I
that's not my list so I want to write
outside looking in like it comedy looks
very frustrating as a profession because
there's really no guideline there's no
there's no ranking there's like it just
it just kind of happens at everyone's
individual pace so to know like I know
you have to be realistic but maybe well
maybe you're supposed to reach a little
bit so out of five years are you
somebody that you really don't want to
have like no no I know a lot of people
who have live in three years Wow
but let me ask you a question what I do
consider a hemline a guy who does 45
minutes or I have mine right okay so yes
there's people who they move up the
ranks quickly I was not one of those
people they move up the ranks a little
bit too quickly and they had lion but I
go back to that Pennzoil commercial from
the nineties you could pay me now but
you can pay me later
oh you have to put the hours on the man
in the same thing you do with jiu-jitsu
same thing you doing karate
all these arts you have to put that time
in there's something about that time now
it can't excuse me what's time Joey okay
let's pretend you are headlining no TV
credits no nothing just funny guy you
got 45 minutes huh
I've heard your [ __ ] before I'm not
calling you a thief I'm just saying that
you know Johnny original right but you
got your moments okay and yeah you're
walking simple ones you're doing one
night of Omaha yeah you're a headliner
but it's a different headline now let's
say you get into one of the chains and
again you still in an Oklahoma but you
work those chains you get in somewhere
yeah I'm saying after
10-12 years you become a good headline
but guess what at the 20 year mark you
become a really [ __ ] good headline
you know it's interesting when we
started the podcast they were speaking
about Dave Chappelle right and right now
you Lee there's a bunch of people are
yelling that think that Dave Chappelle
had the Chappelle show when he came from
that the Chappelle show was what mm I'll
look it up around that time yeah there's
a long time ago mm what is it first
episode aired oh three oh three okay
I know sure pal banging it in 93 I
remember Chappelle being in that movie
Robin Hood men in short men tied yeah
man in tights and you know he had
development when I was doing comedy for
years Chappelle was or reneus on his way
to be a star they just couldn't find the
right vehicle in the 90 professor was
using thought he was doing movies he's
in Conair but they were trying to put
him in a [ __ ] TV show ABC gaming
deals he had a bunch of [ __ ] deals
and if I'm not mistaken even shot a few
pilots then just he had a pilot with
somebody Greg Kinnear somebody had a
pilot with they just could not find the
perfect that look at they found that he
found there with Neal Brennan in a
sketch comedy black show telling the
truth
you know stories tell him the truth
Charlie Murphy a meal so he turned the
whole culture around I mean if you look
at his shows it's not [ __ ] black
people jumping up and down yeah you know
yeah black people all jumping up and
down so let's look at again I like that
he's been doing comedy since the 80s mid
80s late 80s you know he's not this good
because he just got up he's been in
there for 30 years even there for 30
years
what do you I mean that's experience and
experience and and that's not honest I
haven't seen the Comedy Store special
but the first one I saw the first one
opens are talking about how good he is
it was very intimate just [ __ ]
tremendous because it's not what you say
it's how you say it
yeah okay it was very brilliant as I was
looking at it sitting there going to
myself the way he's saying that he's
stealing the show he's not one of them
either
yeah he's not lying he's not good he's
not lying
he knows the other side he mesmerizes
you write a mesmerising you like no
comic as in the last 20 is he has a
different persona tone you know I'm
saying yeah to go for the regular black
man you know for a regular white man he
looks like a harmless black dude you
know the same so I don't know I don't
know what his appeal is he appeals to me
he's a very sweet guy
and I still I guess I saw the first
special and I didn't watch the whole
thing because I was tired
mm-hm you know like I always say you
could watch 30 minutes and then you got
to go to [ __ ] bed and it was just
great just to see that but I know that
body of work took 30 [ __ ] years you
know that took 30 [ __ ] years a lot of
people at home thinks he just they think
he probably just gets up the same way I
thought about stand-up I thought you
just got up and [ __ ] needle yeah you
had it or you did in yeah that's it no
no no no it's just a look in this league
there's tons of work patients eat [ __ ]
taking [ __ ] sleep on floors sleeping on
beds you know your body making you
driver one of the afternoons and sitting
in a strange town for six hours yeah
with nothing to do with it it's just a
thousand [ __ ] things that you sit
there and go what the [ __ ] am i doing my
life but this is your passion maybe this
is one of your final 4k I know it was my
last frontier
there was nothing more past this so
right now you're at the line near more
you feature it yeah right and what are
you looking for for the [ __ ] like what
is a guy like you looking for first of
all like for this year I like I write I
wrote a couple things down you know give
me a pen yeah I don't like doing like
New Year's resolutions
you know I mean I I feel like that's
just sudden you're like you were saying
like with dieting is never gonna work
you know it's a lifestyle change it's
like the same thing news resolutions
they don't [ __ ] work I just write
things down that just makes me keep more
organized and just cross them off one by
one so a couple of things on the list is
I mean I just want to get more spots I
mean I am in a place where I'm seeing
guys that have been doing it less time
than me or the same amount of time as
mean they just get way more spots than I
do
I mean I'm sure that you know they're
out there way more than I am and I just
feel like I kind of hit like a wall and
I want to just maybe kind of start
getting into acting now but like you
said maybe get a commercial agent that's
one thing that I want to do this year
what at the nine year mark for me it was
too I started 91 so what's the 9 years
2000 by 2000 I was doing comedy yeah 9
years I had a [ __ ] shitty manager I
had a shitty agent I was getting pulling
in 80% of the work myself you know me I
will [ __ ] kill her when it comes to
that [ __ ] I was getting breakdowns and I
can't no I'm gonna I lied to you about a
manager from about 98 to 2000 2001 I had
a great manager he was just more
aggressive than what I need that I
thought I wasn't that good she knew how
to [ __ ] take you make you an act to
get you a deal and then put you on the
road with the right people he was born
and raised he was about his kid he was
just too tough too and he had a temper
and he would yell at people and hang up
phones and tell people to go [ __ ]
themselves
well on the other side he
he wasn't scared to pick up the phone
which was why I loved that me call
anybody and try to muscle had any
[ __ ] time I listen man and he was he
was very intelligent before he made the
call he'd get very knowledgeable about
the subject break it down and Korie and
Sadie Angus there's artifacts three
years ago your show on ABC was distance
distance this demographic what you need
isn't long a little rich in character
one comes to my man Joe Diaz at the
improv at 8:30 put - show that's right
I'm into Episode four we could still
save the [ __ ] season you Milo's type
of Jews you know saying so that that was
impressive that you he would she would
call you up on a Monday no listen
Thursday night put together seven
minutes about gambling I'm trying to get
you on this show on HBO I'm having the
writers come down and next you know you
you're talking to the writers and they
tell you what direction and but at least
you get to talk to the people were
putting the show together he got right
to the source
you know he didn't go to the producers
he went right to the writers if he had a
problem he went to a producer hmm I said
your show sucks here's what you need to
save your show Lisa I as a magician and
[ __ ] D'Agostino as a piece of making
an acquisition he's half [ __ ]
that'll make a [ __ ] show he was one
of those type of managers I got with him
I booked basketball okay that book some
mouse but I really worked his account
was that in two thousand I think
basically ball was 98 when I met him I
had just booked the pilot for CBS
he didn't close the deal he he made me
work for a little while and I booked
something like a commercial I book like
a coke commercial and he saw and he
called me who's answering the coke
commercial come on now let's talk next
week so I'll never forget that before he
spoke to me he called a few agents to
try to get me meetings and nobody wanted
to see me except one [ __ ] agent okay
I learned a valuable lesson this day
and he goes meet me at such and such
place he bought me lunch and he goes
here's what's going on I reached out the
13 agents they gave me their names
really just the little ones of me with
it
she was I got one person who's in love
with you let's go see him I go what's
her name he told me I forget what what
her name was this 99 maybe and you know
I think you're looking for an agent you
want to be going the other direction on
Sunset you know the same towards bells
tolling [ __ ] towards the comedy store
the answer and this we met somewhere and
it still I get in the car making a right
he went a laughing like what a [ __ ] away
the next thing you know he's making a
left on Highland
this is 98 he's really not that high oh
my goodness now at 98 Highland was beat
the [ __ ] up but before you hit that
thing where they have parking there like
that a little circle yes okay before you
hit that circle that whole area was
perversion and crack right there I would
go to three days a week and sell pornos
on the phone when I moved here there was
a job that I paid $8 an hour and you go
there and every day was it loot set of
freaks if you've stayed the day they
gave you an extra $10 bonus I would send
you down there it was fun I learned how
to sell [ __ ] I worked there for as long
as I could which was about four weeks
nice old pornos on the phone - no -
[ __ ] mom people watch pornos and
[ __ ] individuals not just oh yeah
they give you a list of names and you
call stores and what's up it's like how
you doing the Agostino here from
whatever films you know I'm gonna call
you to see if you see the new inventory
well you got tell me what you got
so we go [ __ ] sex on sex with minutes
people probably know each other I would
never even watch the movies I would just
take the names and then say yeah 73 for
we haven't I can't wait you're already
thanks for calling yeah you might know a
cow there's people quit all the time but
in there I remember coming out of there
one day walking coked out I
night before yeah just showing up
because I had no wealth to talk to I was
living right there in Hollywood and I
was getting checks in the Taco Bell
commercial and there was two hotels that
were cousins you could stay there for 10
days then they asked you to leave but
you had to go to yellow then for 10 days
you go back to the other one but you
couldn't stay in longer than 10 days and
I since I lived there I didn't want to
go at that time a 6565 sunset that
building was all telemarking you go in
then you get a job that day 10 bucks an
hour selling [ __ ] insurance or
something like that I wanted to sell
born on commission I want to I had money
so I didn't give a [ __ ] I talked about
money
oh sure I was going up there just to
[ __ ] around can I was making a team I
needed that but I still remember one day
walking out of there and buying coke
like that's how bad that Street was and
then that Street there's a middle
building everything it's still there
there's a building that building was
filled with garbage telemarketing scams
all that [ __ ] on the fourth floor was an
agency and I still remember walking into
the hallway and looking up in the
ceiling Tower being removed the north
this is the [ __ ] agent that wants to
sign me I was like embarrassed I was
like heartbroken like all his clients
were top notch [ __ ] agents and nobody
wanted to sign me except this [ __ ]
little five foot two Jewish ball of fire
from Chicago I didn't give a [ __ ] that
war blue [ __ ] blue [ __ ] shadows
[ __ ] over our eyeballs and she'd sit
there all day just pitching you on the
[ __ ] phone like an animal and I was
like I don't know I'll get back to you
over the holiday she seemed [ __ ]
Stern jack she was like listen if you
sign with me this is how we do [ __ ] here
and I was like bro we're the [ __ ]
building that sounds cracked what the
[ __ ] you talking about I walk that night
no I don't feel how heartbroken I was
and then something happened that I had a
sign one as she [ __ ] work guys
this lady was a [ __ ] worker she would
get me out three days a week for
everything and I was on fire would I
forget this [ __ ] I booked
she got me an analyzed that [ __ ]
spider-man - I [ __ ] that movie the T
had a lot of TV if you look at mine DB a
lot of that TV from 99 to 2003 was her
and she sent because her parents owned
the [ __ ] refrigeration kingdom in
Chicago they were millionaire so she
snapped one back then they gave her a
bunch of money something happened
they're trying to make her find the
husband who did you go right away to a
different agent where yeah yeah like
right away you had someone that wanted
you at my door fast no no no no you
still gotta go down the Samuel French
and get the agent book and [ __ ] get
your picture and type of Perez amay and
put them all in there and type up a
cover letter write up a cover letter by
hand
to show them that you're an animal so
how it works still today that's the only
way I would do it so like di like
describe what you're going through right
now
like maybe let's just be like what's
like trying to get an agent her manager
without when anyone you don't have one I
mean I don't even know how where to
begin
I've never tried I never even for
stand-up I've never had an agent I never
had a manager I mean when you were at
the 9-point you had one already I guess
huh while I was here I was here and
there were things going on so did I
I needed one to help me get acting stuff
that's why I went with her I had no
choice but to go with her because Jeff
who was my managers a sign he had
assistance to working things okay when
he would get up in the morning and Jeff
would get up at 5:00 a.m. and he would
look through the breakdowns were all the
jobs of it
so by 6:30 and there would be 50 pages
of breakdown status keys and he knew all
his clients in his head and you just go
through all these sheets and circle the
clients that you want for our dishes
he's a circle and then most people do
what traditional people do what I did
you take a headshot you put a resume and
then you put a cover letter and pray for
the best pray that she actually opens it
and takes you had shut up but people
like that could send the picture
messenger she has to sign for it which
means she'll open it and then they call
if you look at a lot of breakdowns they
always say on top we do not accept calls
that's for [ __ ] people believe that
[ __ ] to get your clients in there you've
got a call if you don't call you're not
gonna get clients
you're gonna call and see what's going
on this is what we have for this booth
D'Agostino he just moved here from Italy
yes it doesn't matter he's perfect for
the role you're gonna love so talk about
was 94 what did you saying that Enoch
LaBelle was like 98 so you were 97 98 7
8 years and a stand-up he already did it
commercial I was a stand-up yeah I was I
got here in 97 and I've been doing
stand-up six and a half years seven
years but as soon as I got here that was
the one thing I got signed to the best
commercial agent in town sudden Bart the
Minari at the time was top-notch all
across the board and brother he was like
I signed with some weight on a Tuesday
it took like a week I got like one or
two and then it took off like if you
didn't book with them you're not gonna
have a future because nobody did a
better job it didn't stop I had a pager
in those days
Rogan has spoken about an R in those
guys I had a pager in those days those
days does how you day started from 6:00
at night to about 8:00 you'd get a page
or a call hey D'Agostino how you doing
Michael Dell
son Bart Ehrman re you going in tomorrow
for tide 10:45 Santa Monica from
straight yet dressed with a red shirt
okay
Thank You boom that's it you got a 1045
that's how you day started so will you
or not that night to do comedy you knew
how to go home early gotta go home early
and get some sleep because you had to be
at Santa Monica first Street at [ __ ]
10:45 you get out boldly breakfast shoot
down to Santa Monica
walk in there about 10 o'clock you know
gonna get in there early and get the
[ __ ] out laughter you get the rest of
your day going
you go down eight you you read by the
time you walk out of that to your car
you got another patient
where you at I'm walking out a Taco Bell
alright take the car go to Ocean Drive
you got a 12:15 you know like [ __ ] 12:15
I came down there at 10:00 I was doing
the right thing so they got I said down
there that's why you bring a book a
movie whatever and then I went to the
other play and then when you walked out
of there you got in your car and you
made it all the way back to Hollywood
and by the time you make it back to
Hollywood maybe an hour later you can
another page at where yet Hollywood
perfect go down to 200 southla brand
they're looking for a plumber for a
[ __ ] Geico commercial and you went
over by Petco on La Brea yeah on top
ladders auditioning up there and you
went there parked your car
you couldn't park in the parking lot the
[ __ ] side street is four to six and
the [ __ ] front is [ __ ] on quarter
for two seconds
you know saying there's a corner for
three seconds right time you turn around
you call his gun and there's a black
chick with a fucked-up head - with
Donuts on the air [ __ ] giving you a
$52 ticket
so it's torture dog it's torture it's a
it's a horrible living because sometimes
you go upstairs and you forget to come
down and put a quarter in the meter and
you come on you got a $52 [ __ ]
telephone all that [ __ ] will you go for
auditions is heavy-duty ticketing so you
better have ten thousand corners in your
[ __ ] car at all times I only ever
wanted to be a stand-up like you know
what I mean like I don't
I never reached out to try to get a
commercial agent ever and I didn't
either but the problem is that it's the
back door right and sometimes you have
to look sometimes you have to go to the
back door to get to the front door you
know so that was the way I looked at it
my strategy was I came here and I was
already a regular at the store that
really [ __ ] help me so that put me in
the other two clubs kind of sorted
Jamie let me do Monday nights and The
Improv gave me one maybe two spots a
week if I was lucky so from the store I
worked that angle like I would just but
you have to it was a different time then
it wasn't 911 yet before 9/11 whoo
laughs the land wasn't security
tightened and casting AIDS it won't let
you go with the Sony no more like there
was a time I could walk up to a Sony
game and I could have an envelope and go
I mean to see Carol Witherspoon what's
your name Joey Diaz I just want to drop
this off I don't need to see it it's for
an audition and the guard Lou you from a
different edition and he's like in did
you go to her office and drop the
envelope off and the casting assistant
would see and she go who you're on the
Agostino I'm here to drop this off for
the role of Rudy I just saw it to break
downs I thought it'd be good for it and
she's looking and going that's great
give me a number
if you leave your number you get an
audition so that doesn't happen anymore
down there I don't think people have the
spunk to do that anymore so it's not
that it's frowned on to do it no no no
you listen as a casting director your
job is to book that job with the right
person you don't give a [ __ ] way you
find them if I feel if I felt that
aggressive friend I gotta chase them
I went after maybe 12 roles aggressively
and I probably got a them what
percentages were high
you know maybe in casting they decided
to make the guy black or thin or they
wanted to go with a more seasoned actor
somebody of that
the name but all those two angles I took
like that I would drop all packed like I
remember dropping off an envelope one
time for all this I'm getting a call
that afternoon and book of it and I
ended up being an episode with James
Coburn Wow you know the tape with the
producers or one of my friends from the
comedy store was a producer huh
so it was an envelope I dropped off
that's that's a different type of mind
game that's to keep yourself busy see it
when I [ __ ] when you slip before what
did you attorney in there trying to sue
somebody don't tell you gotta go to the
doctor so every day you still go to
therapy or anything you would go to the
scan because you're putting the time and
you're punching it yeah
the same applies to this career that we
have the boy you punch it to some of you
more you get from it if somebody's
giving a free acting class and North
Hollywood High School for the sixth or
learn and you can make it make it I go
for free and get the basics then [ __ ]
around and paid $1 do you them saying
yeah the little more you take especially
just want to dabble a little bit in any
way you don't worry listen you don't
need to be Olivier the book [ __ ] I was
no Libby able that booth the Taco Bell
commercial made me [ __ ] money that I
never seen before
you know when I booked a pilot for CBS I
was no [ __ ] Olivier you know I was
just a regular [ __ ] small I had a look
they liked you know it's a [ __ ] up
look you know I adhered to their role
and I lucked out you know I can play
like a pimp I can play a gangster I can
play an Italian [ __ ] hitman I can
play a [ __ ] visa man I can play
garbage really and on this vu you know
there's so many [ __ ] things I could
do they just is so specific you get a
lot more work than I did at that age
your age right now you get a lot more
additions then I would get when I got
here cuz when I got here I was pretty
sudden [ __ ] years old I was already
longer than toot by that standard
what about the guy who's got the day job
and you know just wants to be a stand-up
comic so that's what he does at night
and so now he wants to get into acting
commercial
you know just to get some work that way
I mean at their page and you have three
times and a day there's no day job
anymore no you gotta let go of it it's
what you're doing using it right so you
would be you would get a lot of work at
the beginning the season Europe you
would just get a lot of work and watch
em like I say the more involved you are
the more chances you got it going on a
roll there's nothing like going on a row
until you're ready like there's a guy
used to train with that one on a [ __ ]
three months roll listen that may never
happen to him again or he may stay like
this for a long time but going on the
road is shooting the job taking a week
off shoot another job taking a week off
shooting job that is supposed to be a
weekend a job every week like I booked
for national commercials four weeks in a
row three three three three weeks in a
row on a Thursday a shot of national
commercial wow that is crazy for me
that's crazy but excuse me I was very
lucky there's people in Hollywood that
shoot a commercial every week and you
see it you guys that watch TV see these
people
the same commercial actors and
everything they shoot every week bro
because let me tell you something you
should every week because after show you
shoot don't get picked up
that's a scary I mean it's scary just to
thinking about how much time and and
money is spent on things that people
will never see like that's another thing
that must like we always talk about
people who left but like I don't think
we consider like like how terrible some
things must be to deal with like look
you mad like we I know bill burr I have
to show canceled he's left and came back
but like that that that like there must
be things that happen to you I'll throw
out your career that would make you want
to go home
nothing makes you really want to go home
if this is what you really want to do I
mean you know saying yeah but you really
want to do you you know the process you
know the deal you've heard the [ __ ]
stories this isn't something that you
know just came to you this is part of
the process you just don't take your
ball and go home when it starts raining
you just don't take your ball and go
home you wait for the rain to [ __ ] it
you're going through a bad streak and
unless you listen unless you're getting
blown by [ __ ] people want a peep show
for two dollars a night for the state or
to be in Koreatown or something like
that you're sucking [ __ ] Japanese
dick in Koreatown it's not that bad here
there's always an existence here I don't
give a [ __ ] what you tell me there's
always a job somewhere you can be a
[ __ ] busboy and somebody's always got
a couch in this town you know why cuz I
did it for the first four or five years
I was here thank God for people like
Ralphie May and Josh wolf and others
that let me [ __ ] you know go [ __ ]
hand to mouth on a daily basis but let
me tell you something I never sat there
all day
I always hustle brother I always dropped
off an envelope
I was always somewhere trying to write a
joke and I was on stage every [ __ ]
night I didn't have a child
I really had I had a girlfriend
sometimes I
responsibility and then wanted
responsibility I did comedy for a living
and that's how I thought that was my
that was my brain I didn't care about
holidays I didn't care about New Year's
I think about seeing people I sacrificed
that part of my life for years to do
calmly you know I would call the store
in those days Sunday the Sunday these
last two weeks I would get spot seven
nights a week at the store you know I
was always at this floor but I wouldn't
get to restore till midnight so what you
gonna do come in they say yeah or fall
asleep so I would go to Willie Barcena
his rooms and all those rooms yeah and
just sharpen up my and you know and
there's still those rooms out that those
rooms are there I just not hip to it
because they don't all know more because
you know why I'm not gonna one of those
[ __ ] shoot him up rooms no more
unless it's like a friend a man who I
really trust and like I go out a lot
during the week I know about all those
rooms I mean I'm doing those spots and
you know there's just uh
there's just something you know like I
probably shouldn't feel this way but
like so you know you're going like
Twitter or something or Instagram you
start seeing like everything from the
night before just like you feel like I'm
missing out on stuff you know there's
always comics I'm doing something that
it better than me you know I mean so I
don't know I feel like I've hit a wall
here or like people know me but they
don't you know I occasionally get spot
to the store they're giving me like once
a month and now like not anymore
and so I I mean that just like you said
I think that I have to go through the
back door now I've hit a point where
it's like I got a switch like a tide
switch something up I got to go in
another way let's talk about the bike
greetings from podcast greetings from
podcast Ville the Church of what's
happened now was brought to you by the
zip recruiter listen a fresh new year
has begun and if you set new goals for
your business it's extremely difficult
to reach them without the right people
on your team zip recruiter has
transformed how you go about finding
them
does it preclude approach your job to
over a hundred of the web's leading job
boards with just one click find out
today why the zip recruiter has been
used by businesses of all sizes and
industries to find them
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now today the church
family can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right free free free
just go to zip recruited dot-com slash
Church that zip recruiter dodge no that
zip recruiter dot-com slash Church one
more time I messed that one up that zip
recruiter comm slash Church get the best
talent available to you right now number
two you know what you're number two new
year resolution should be I'm gonna wash
my ass more this year I'm gonna have my
ass tip top Magoo four times a day
because from time to time I put my hand
down there and I'm scared to wave it cuz
[ __ ] birds will come down and I'm
saying that's why you got hello pushy
go - hello - she's calm and use code
church for 10% off your order
why walk around with a filthy [ __ ]
[ __ ] and not stinking like a dead man
when you can have a portable bidet right
now you could use it even if you don't
[ __ ] you sometimes just in the mood to
wash your balls you could dip your
nutsack into that but they turn that
nice little cold water on so come up
with that new water and that new soap
that liquid soap and sponging but like a
[ __ ] loofah you know what happens to
your nut stick top Magoo you gotta bathe
people be paying you to suck your
[ __ ] nuts a go - hello - she calm
right now
and press in church for a 10% discount
60-day money-back guarantee and he nine
one of the [ __ ] sign me for comedy
there was really developed me there was
a rare then it went away it went away
because I had a pitch and the pitch was
okay until HBO said nah we know well
they're gonna do that we're going into
the holiday so the guy from CAA and like
me until that one away that was what
happened but at that time I realized
Montreal wasn't gonna the dirty show
that was all [ __ ] they were not
gonna give me a shot so I was like what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do
and I was second time and going to
movies just like stand-up you one day
you know when they go you keep going to
your local club and then booking these
[ __ ] morons and when they just go
[ __ ] this I'm gonna disappear for a
month and I'm gonna go get really good
and come back and rock that's exactly
what you do yeah and now you're getting
worked at but the same thing happens
with stand-up how do you become a
stand-up you're watching TV and you go
what the [ __ ] I'm funny in this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then said but well acting
the same thing happens how many times
are you in a movie in you know ways that
I could have done this wrong yep
yeah like I was past watching analyze
this the first one I went on a date tell
me what her ask him that I got for now
what are you why is that look on your
face and I was like no no nothing the
lights bothered me or whatever I was
just angry because I was living here I
didn't know about any of this [ __ ] yeah
I got was pissed about it let me tell
you what else uncle Joey did but I think
I mentioned on the podcast one time I
had this goofy manager goofy goofy good
dude though good dude
solid I still talk to him I wasn't one
of it this time
how was it Jeff Gallen and I'm in New
York City and I'm just doing like
Rascals on doing the old governor's well
there was a [ __ ] armpit
this is 98 99 I'm doing Jesus Christ I'm
doing like [ __ ] gigs for Rodger Paul you
know one-niners and stuff and
I wasn't I was at with loops and I'm in
Jersey I mean Chinese fulham there for
like four days and I go into the city
and I drop off a tape for something some
TV show that Gatlin's told me to then he
called me the next thing he goes you
ever another real maker yet and I
dropped it off at some other place and
then one day
guess who [ __ ] calls me well manager
was a bench I just got off the phone
with this lady she wants you to drop a
tape off for this new show The Sopranos
I know what is it about singers my life
the singers and she goes I really don't
know I think it's something to do with
the Mafia something like that and that's
a tape by the drop off but you know what
what difference will that make
you know I had booked [ __ ] I hadn't
[ __ ] like that before I didn't
really know the variables are going in
there later on I went in for The
Sopranos but at that time but the first
thing I did was I'll never forget I was
in a [ __ ] hotel room in Dallas Texas
and it was Sunday morning and I was on
fire
I was on fire I was at the store every
[ __ ] night which are Rogen and Eddie
Griffin and Andrew Dice Clay and Paul
Mooney and Doug Stanhope
and it just got me sharp like I had been
on the road for nine months you know I
went on the road on left in 99 and came
back in 2000 I used to do all those
[ __ ] there was a big shootout here
people hear sirens and helicopters we
heard about what eight or nine [ __ ]
gun fights here so do you know I don't
know buy the train they could have been
by the train station so it was a [ __ ]
weak dog when I went to Dallas and I
don't want to say that line I was
working with well I was [ __ ] burying
him I was just buried him guys and it
was getting obvious it was starting to
get obvious it was starting to God and
all away I was like 35 did any part of
you think about towing it down not even
close this is Dallas Texas and I was
going on there before this guy just
buried him I was doing blow I was eating
like a savage you know I didn't really
give a [ __ ] I never forget waking up in
a hotel room that's Sunday morning all
of like I woke up like from the coke a
little pissed off and I'm like I can't
believe I'm here taking orders from this
[ __ ] mutt he's probably getting three
grand for the week and Here I am getting
a small [ __ ] to 750 you know with no
[ __ ] plane ticket and I gotta stay
and do an extra show on Sunday for the
handicapped or something it's so [ __ ]
you know some [ __ ] you know you're
like what no what the [ __ ] is my career
going I mean I'm very fortunate to have
this feature work but this is [ __ ] I
can be [ __ ] to knock him out of the park
he ain't doing no special ain't nobody
coming to see him yeah nobody feel him
to see this [ __ ] fool you know it's
like he's a headliner now and he was a
headline of me
and he's getting 15 I'm you're getting 5
500 and they barely want to give me that
I'll never forget I came home when I
borrow 500 bucks from Joshua like a sow
like 500 bucks and I went to the soup
place in Hollywood Seattle I got three
suits for 200 bucks and I went to a van
and champa can sign up for acting
classes then I gave her the rest of her
money and I say I'm not going on the
road and just had to take acting classes
and I went to acting class this is how I
did the back way if you really want to
know
I went to buy acting classes and I still
did stand-up at night but I focused a V
on what they were talking about and
again I start talking to people in
acting classes
any of these people playing two miles a
month times three cuz they're gonna
three different things a month for
classes for training and they're not
even working they're being told they're
not even perfect talk for work and I'm
looking at these guys going these
[ __ ] kids serious like I'm telling
you you're paying me money and I'm
telling you D'Agostino you'll either
you're not ready to go to work on film
and TV I'm like I'm appalled so even
thought was an event at Chadwick the
first two or three weeks I was doing
good scenes like my first scene was the
scene from Carlinhos way
when the attorney goes to see the
mobster when Sean Penn goes to see the
mobster how to play the mobster and they
don't want you to say it they want you
to say it verbatim but they want you to
be your own character
a tendon when I got off that [ __ ]
stage dog those people in there was
shaking my hand like I was [ __ ]
Hemingway like I was some [ __ ]
tremendous actor I was just a dirty
comic I didn't know nothing about
[ __ ] I think I'm right there I'm
going wait a second and that's what I
heard they're shootin Annalise - I got
full audition for some [ __ ] movie and
this is how it started I went from
audition for some [ __ ] movie that was
not right for as I was reading the line
I kept thinking about that dude the
Mexican dude that started in in Marcos
the first season he's the chubby dude
with the hat
Luis all those dumbass
when I was [ __ ] I was on his pilot I
shot his pilot yeah good one man Luis
Guzman I shot his pilot for Fox but as I
was reading for this movie I could read
Luis Guzman I'm like this is Luis Guzman
throw why am I wasting my time and at
the end of the read the lady said that
was a good read but you're not right for
this role I don't thank God you thought
the same way this is for a Mexican
person and she goes yes she goes but
you're gonna be right for my next point
but like what's your next wish analyze
that part too mmm that was it I go so
what do I need to be in there
and she goes stay in touch with me send
me anything you work on anything you
book send me a copy in the table it was
like you got it and I went to work Jack
and I booked the Mafia thing a gay mafia
effect
and I booked that and I took the clip
from that immediately and sent that over
Turner had booked something else is that
when you played the cake guy yeah you
guys are burying the body in a cemetery
that's [ __ ] funny I booked some
mother died booked something else that
was mafia theme and I got a copy with a
senator immediately and then I got the
call one day BAM you're auditioning
finalized that but in New York don't I
couldn't get the [ __ ] in San Jose I
didn't have a dime they hit the [ __ ]
mayor maybe or New York to audition yep
and there's no flight I can put a gig
together when I was dead make a hundred
bucks or Rascals but not enough to cover
my [ __ ] hair fan or make me a
millionaire and I like that now to sleep
on somebody's floor you know so a friend
of mine from the old days reached out
and he goes I got a plane ticket for you
I'm [ __ ] frontier and where's all
those [ __ ] hell Airlines
you gotta stop in Denver and they chase
your luggage over by the time I got to
New York they lost my luggage I had to
go buy a warm-up suit and sneakers
they didn't do like audition tapes back
then no you had a show to put these
mortgage and then you they wanted you to
stay to talk to the director
because you're not getting [ __ ]
booking this movie and peut aqua
directness so you were like hi you were
like at least being considered then at
this level why they're not gonna fly it
and I gotta tell 30 people to fly in New
York no there was no I wouldn't tape it
it happened something like that I
wouldn't a but I want to be in the
[ __ ] room I don't think a lot of
people work for I want to know I want to
make sure that if I don't get this I
didn't get this because it wasn't me I
don't want to get this because I sent
the tape I want them to meet me I want
them to see me walk into the room I want
them to see my patois my Janis a quad
you know I'm saying as they say in
[ __ ] France
so that was my big thing where did you
learn that like things like I want them
to see me walk in like where did you
comment just think about that think
about that think about that well what do
I get what essence do I get from
watching you on tape no yeah for sure
yeah it's probably cut down by at least
half if not more but little things like
you one second how come I do even though
you make a fantastic [ __ ] stand-up
HBO I was special how can I really book
you for a 30 million dollar feet nor
eighty five million dollar feature next
the wolf submit without Megan you commit
you gotta send me a tape to encourage me
to make you commit that's the that's the
tape you sent to me for meeting okay
make him coming in read but most people
reside in New York will going for that
audition right right you just went
because she liked you for that yeah yeah
it's important to stay in touch like do
you think a lot of actors have been in
that situation than just didn't send her
or anything but if you go to my email
old the last two pages is all casting
directors I've kept in touch with over
the years like they all got a Merry
Christmas and [ __ ] for me this life like
even though I haven't seen him
over the years you develop relationship
disease casting people back to the
Agostino situation sweats once I went to
acting class the Agostino yeah I learned
a little bit hard but I didn't go in
there to learn how to act I learned how
to get work as an actor again I wanted
to see what they were doing you know you
go behind the Comedy Store or any family
club in any country there's a circle of
kids comics and they talk about what
they're gonna do and how they're gonna
do it and you go back there ten years
later still they and I got it yeah I
just auditioned for asking you only
that's great you know keep sending tapes
and [ __ ] because you did it you didn't
sit there and talk about it and when you
go to acting classes in Hollywood like I
had this at this point I hadn't been to
maybe two acting classes advantage
shopping is considered a high level
there's her and Lesley con that
considered high level there's a few
others that have popped up over the
years in fact somebody sent you a link
to only the ad there and there was
intensive acting or whatever but I went
to a rather Chubut to begin a class and
that's what I went to do I was gonna
learn how to act I went to talk to these
other [ __ ] kids to see if they were
working and guess what another one were
working they were all petrified of
stepping out of that [ __ ] comfort
zone of that acting class and I'll never
forget being at a party one night and
sitting at a bar coked up and there was
a guy and I love a guy I'd shake talking
and the guy goes so what's going on with
you and he goes well tomorrow would do
the scene from Rain Man acting class and
they were so excited like really an
acting class oh my god that's so
thrilling
I hope the teacher she really sees you
for what you want I'm sitting on oh my
god so they become career acting class
people they just pay the 275 a month
they go down there they do the acting
classes and they buy into it that
they're letting the meth in the whole
thing meanwhile I'm seeing this and I
find out about the breakdowns I find out
about the breakdowns
and I go okay so you look at the
breakdown it's the same thing as
anything else you see a job you think
you're perfect for get the ad just get
that [ __ ] phone them go down there
drop the [ __ ] package off and call
them an hour later and ask him if they
want to see you if they like when you
drop off or if they want to see tape I
always created the opportunity to go
back there you forgot something don't
give them everything give them one piece
at a time if you bring the tape in your
resume that's it they don't need to see
you again but if you bring your resume
he'll look at you know what happened to
your table
I didn't know you wanted one well come
back with the tape boom even though he's
mad at you you're gonna come back and
guess what's gonna happen you're gonna
come back he's not gonna be there with
his assistant that'll be that
and she knows you from the barbecue
truck we need new communists she always
thinks you're cute [ __ ] so guess what
you just got an audition because you
forced yourself to go back there a
second time it's all numbers I mean when
it comes to acting it's a completely
different animal it's how many times
they see you before that audition but
guess what if you see something or you
hear or something that your rightful you
really gotta raise your hand and attack
at the acting world cuz they're not
gonna find you they're not gonna find
you your manager your agent I'm gonna
get you in it for so much I know for a
fact from me when it came to acting I
hustled 60% of those jobs
I still remember booking cold case out
of the computer cold case I booked from
the [ __ ] computer at that time it was
on show fax whatever that is then it's a
it's a thing for actors I'm still on
there now I haven't paid no ah well I'm
still on there like those casting
websites that say yeah am i right for
this time you pay $69 a month
$69 a year and those days I got it for
the whole year and you'd [ __ ] submit
from there and let me tell you something
there was a movie I booked from there
but I got fired from I got the money
anyway and there was that for sure that
I remember and there was cold case on
CBS the episode just called fern oh yeah
look after the computer how many worked
do you think actually gets generated
generated from sites like that do you
think people actually get work like that
or you just got lucky a couple times do
you think that's kind of just like
[ __ ] and people don't really get
stuff back so I think that casting
assistants look into that they don't
really look at it like very thoroughly
they skim through it and they'll go look
at your resume and [ __ ] like that really
fast
by that point I was getting jobs already
you know saying so but no you always
have to do you always have to put that
thing at scam it it's always going back
oh you didn't want me to bring you a
tape you ever go to the comedy club yeah
I'll swing by and drop off four tickets
for a copy store Vinny Curto who I speak
about on the podcast right I had on the
church when I first moved here I bumped
into him at the Comedy Store and he said
he had a role for me and one of his
movies I just met the guy I had seen him
a Miami Vice I saw him in the movie
don't name 29th Street and he impressed
me and he was very nice to me it was
half Cuban which was very sweet
and I bumped into one other time he gave
me the address of who to send the
package to a facting and I put together
a package while I had that day I had
been I've been I've been on the CBS
pilot and that was it and I had done
like everything else in that resume was
[ __ ] except for the county worked
everything else was [ __ ] my lowly
[ __ ] I dropped off the package no real
headshot resume byah and I dropped it
off two or three weeks I didn't hear
nothing so at this time I had got into a
system to send [ __ ] out and drop stuff
off Monday and Tuesday with my heavy
days so that meant Sunday night after I
am seen at the store till about 1:00 or
12:00
even when I was snorting blow I would
still go home
snort blow drink alcohol and lick
envelopes and get him ready for the next
couple of days there was Sun heaven lo
she could send that and there was
someone who had deliver on a hand by
model to model to really get the most
out of you quality because you want the
casting assistant to see see these
casting assistants a young and yes what
they do it right they go to comedy clubs
they can't come up to you and say hello
because also talk to a casting assistant
who [ __ ] to you you'll talk to them once
or twice but guess what don't recognize
you don't go oh my god I just saw you
last week at the pink pussycat and
you're like you go to the Prix pussycat
yeah they don't want to go to Congress
throw the improv there won't be a little
different so they go to alternative
places and they come next thing you know
you have an audition you know the
weirdest thing ever was in the head I
wanted for the commitment is that the
machine is hope destroyed that machine
is show The Mentalist yes why did the
Mentalist I went to the audition the
first day and there was [ __ ] 80 people
in the room I'm like I'm not gonna get
this but took a picture with Steven
Bhawani retweeted and that man I had a
message from the [ __ ] author of the
book what role do you want well I said
this one the next day they called me and
offered me a role and it's interesting
it's written bro you never know how
you're gonna pop a role everything works
that way but if you're not involved
like I shouldn't like there would have
been a time when I would've gone final
addition looked in that room and crashed
and left and then the dry wood it
realize what a big [ __ ] mistake that
met because I had nothing else to do and
I was gonna get a chance to talk to
people and find out about different [ __ ]
because that's what audition is
audition you know people always go to
you Wow you have to go to bars yeah the
[ __ ] number one place to find out
about jobs is our auditions when you see
other working actors they're not there
because they're [ __ ] taking acting
classes buying into the [ __ ]
Scientology knows little they're there
because they told those people that [ __ ]
go [ __ ] themselves they're working and
these people bang it out that commercial
life is [ __ ] rough you know you're
right
if I but I don't know how to look how
busy in this D'Agostino I really don't
find my god adequately a job mm-hmm have
one boy if it's that busy you'll just go
I'm quittin because I can't live off
this it's a weird thing
it's just a very [ __ ] weird
occupation just watching some football
on Sunday and I saw this open mic or
that it kind of came up with on a
[ __ ] Home Depot commercial it's
insane my god I just see you in a Home
Depot commercial he's like yeah he just
started he just started to going out for
him Scotty that's how it is because they
like new faces they like new blood huh
everybody they see they know they see
these people once a week but they gotta
see and they trust you and they don't
know what the producer wants
listen unless you go come on shore
dishes people get mad at them and I
gotta tell you some now and an inside
I missed not going because me at this
Ames I probably go for for a year but
I'd be so [ __ ] excited well I'm
driving the Ocean Drive because I know
exactly what I don't eat exactly what a
park you know I've been doing if he is
you're not a noob you when you go he's
like for you you think you booked one a
year yeah if I go to for commercial
edition G because they only be for the
usual suspects the pizza guy I'm off you
do the [ __ ] something you know and I
call I spoke to Lawrence a few weeks ago
we're trying to work on something but
yeah I'm tickling going back out for
commercial auditions because its
fundamentals you learn how to go back to
[ __ ] it's a different type of acting
your mind works differently like I
always tell people when I go for mobster
roles from movies and TV and we're a
black with dark shirt for commercials I
wear a white shirt what's in it what's
the point that commercials your
commercial has to run in Iowa the same
way as it has to run in New York City
a lot of times you have to paint the
picture for the director I don't want
you to go for commercials especially I
don't want you to go when they're
dressed like the guide to the tea I want
you to wear something that camouflages
what you're really worried but you see
that shirt right there you have one okay
the most distinguishing thing about that
shirt other strings
well I went in for basketball I wore a
shirt with strings because it signifies
a whistle round in there ah that's what
it looks like sometimes appearances just
make it seem like what they are you go
from being and span all the way to just
like I made this band will wear gray
sure don't weigh your name just let them
know how you look on this shirt that's
tailored as opposed to you going from
bass ketball with an actual whistle
around your neck that's just their you
exalted there you go yeah there you go
those [ __ ] never get dick gonna
see those guys in there I always see the
guy you go for commercial dishes that
dress like a baked thing at the chef's
hat yeah don't do that don't do that
don't do that I don't give a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] agent tells you like the
agent will call you know by the way they
want you to wear a chef at the red paint
where no [ __ ] ever I'll wear a
baseball hat that's white what if they
say they want you to wear a white shirt
today will you go and we're in it not
white shirts for the standout or now
whatever just [ __ ] wear white shirt
oh I'll see what the role is who the
people are and what the situation is
there's always I got this audition when
I was out I would have had to go all the
way up to the valley
I will never made it back okay no
worries in the salmon look to your
dishes at Santa Monica you got to go all
the way back up to Woodland Hills to get
a white shirt unless you want me to go
buy a white shirt and you always do have
a white shirt in the car yeah sometimes
you want to mess with their head too
it's a different way so you were white
in commercials when then why do you wear
black and for movies because movies are
more realistic that was my strategy
always commercials are [ __ ] more for
the national people this is you know I
can't scare people in Iowa with these
[ __ ] commercials these commercials
I'm trying to make you like me and the
product slobbered always going in a
white shirt now and always booked toast
everybody who went in there with a black
shirt wouldn't bug it those are little
things I love because after you go to
acting class it's gonna take you to six
months to 18 months to learn the ropes
of auditioning to put all the pieces
together all the components that you
have to reach for you have to use a
little bit of your stand-up [ __ ] at
night but I can't tell you what it is
this is what acting coaches don't tell
you yeah especially when you're a
stand-up comic what I want you to do is
separate itself from the comedian
D'Agostino but I still want you to be
that so separate yourself in than a
comedian and you're still there in that
room it's still the same stuff as
stand-up you ever see the movie what's
some more with De Niro a Pacino and the
black kid that he plays football
I think a thank you for the time you
know what is it I don't know you guys
are terrible movie
[Music]
little placements
it's about football or lettuce uh Louis
Taylor yeah I was right any given Sunday
how did give up there's a thing I'm
gonna be given some day then always is
stuck with me and I figured that out
with acting especially the stand-up
comic there's a scene we cuz listen
forget about what's going on clean your
mud I want you to think about being a
kid being a funny your mom this house
it's five to five your mom yells out
honey come on in we're eating dinner you
got one more play you have a lot before
you do the play but it's the same thing
as usual run to the Cadillac and cut
left and you score this is the same
thing when you're playing pro football
just in a small level so would stand up
stand up is that an acting a very close
you're not gonna go and then do your own
material you're gonna stick to the
script but what you're gonna borrow from
stand-up is the bravado the [ __ ] you
know you're a stand-up so
psychologically I can do this with my
eyes closed
so you have to bring that tight but if
they see a casting agent is just like
anything else if they see blood they
don't know you're weak so you gotta walk
in there with the standup type of lavato
that everybody knows when you walk in
they know you're a [ __ ] real estate
I've got your timing is own and you go
in there you're gonna provide you listen
to the director that's them every
director is gonna make you do something
different
even if you're doing it right you know
what he wants to make sure that you
listen he wants to make sure you could
be directed so when you go in those
rooms at the right you do it right and
the director goes do me a favor do it
again but at the end jump up and down
and then you jump up and down on the way
home you know why didn't make me jump up
and down he wanted to see me to follow
the right factual did stuff like that
yeah they have to see if you're gonna be
easy to work with they have bed tricks
and you have to have yours
it's very interesting what I learned
though she is it made me a [ __ ]
animal
it made me an enema I've always felt
that a stand-up comic can get into
acting easier look at them look at that
anyone look at them rappers get it at
stand-up comics getting it but I don't
think actors can get into stand-up
comedy as easy
no no they try it's it's this is a
process brother I want people at home to
understand this always this is a [ __ ]
process we brought up a great point to
be any other podcast and you know I've
seen people headline in 18 months and
brag about it and I'm happy for but I
know that anyway they're about to get
[ __ ] doomed anyway and it's such a
beating that you get Lee that some of
those headlines and I'm a headline of
Beaton's of tough to recover from you at
this point as terrible doesn't light
sound do you look forward to the people
of people getting those beatings yes yes
I cheer for them to get beatings because
this is what's gonna snap them out of it
this is what is a makes them quit or
make you a stand-up comic I still member
covering for Jimmy Shubin in
Jacksonville at that hotel down there
for five nights and I ain't dick every
[ __ ] show is I have
I had no idea what I was doing I still
have nightmares of that audience just
staring at me just waking up in the
middle of night to a bunch of [ __ ]
white people my specific faces oh yeah
oh yeah I still remember that night I
remember my bad bombs they stick with
you like if I believe is psychological
like a five-seater Ned it was it was a
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Friday was great cause it was all you
can eat seafood night CD is that real
quick before you study [ __ ] in blow on
stage before you had brown leakage on
your pants round out states they gave
you those crabs from Neptune New Jersey
that had like boy jor-el on them for the
[ __ ] sixties
I haven't heard him that to New Jersey
the whole [ __ ] Jack Nicholson anyone
wait think of me and Jack Nicholson okay
so I was high as [ __ ] I'm not really
saying yeah he starts these [ __ ]
things putting in limbo and then you mix
them with stars and this [ __ ] tree
for this you want a cookie right now
cookies on family he knows how many
point those are he's like yeah six
points together sorry she cooks healthy
her yeah yeah so put like half the
powder you have to sugar it half the
butter whatever they [ __ ] put in this
thing so the first thing on your plan is
you're still gonna do four spots a week
yeah so that's 16 spots a month so it's
[ __ ] ten spots is 160 and then you
got throw it you're in the month that
you're in the year round with 192 which
isn't bad and you're a writer so you'll
try new [ __ ] in between you're also
gonna try to book two commercials
I try to get a commercial agent which is
gonna be a three-month task or it could
be a two-day task
hmm it's up to you you gotta go Donnell
Sam you're French I get the commercial I
know a couple agents that I'll sign you
and they'll get you out well don't get
your [ __ ] out and that's what you want
you want to go out to you get
comfortable the more you go out the
better you get just like being on stage
yeah it's just like being on stage and
that's the backyard that I took I was
thought the story and I like banging out
with those gorillas but in the daytime I
was auditioning for anything and
everything anything and everything and
then you know they would raise the
stakes from time to time and I would go
all the way to the end and I'll get it
played at least that was the mix I was
the mix for a ton of [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
but I couldn't get on holdings cried and
taking my ball and said [ __ ] those
[ __ ] you're gonna be a
Scientologist or worse but I knew that
the more nose I got I was getting closer
I knew up there was a lot of this [ __ ]
and that's the Sopranos they were making
a lot of [ __ ] and they were looking for
guys like me so I knew I was gonna throw
I went out every couple days I went out
for something they were throwing his
[ __ ] me all the time and there was a lot
of stuff I turned down
I just wanted for the audition for
practice I bought a book called audition
I think that yeah that that's the first
thing I read when I moved here you buy
that Samuel French and help me toward
agree but the thing that pushed me over
the top was doing storytelling on stage
from going to a desperate stand-up
comedian because you're desperate for
laughs as a stand-up but the biggest
bridge to cross is when you tame the
audience and tell a story it's a
different type of patience and a lot of
comics can't take it that's a lot of
silence for a punchline that's a lot of
silence for a woman for a payout so a
lot of people fall in the crack
they spin right out into a joke and I
destroyed the whole thing yeah because
people smell their fear
so it's it's that's what really taught
me how to audition while I was up there
telling the story I said oh [ __ ] look
what I'm doing
I'm auditioning it's the same [ __ ]
thing it's three minutes when I go in
those rooms I'm doing the [ __ ]
three-minute bit for these people and I
remember going in for a thousand things
that were one line and I would get so
pissed D'Agostino hold the elevator
excuse me is this Broadway that type of
[ __ ] and I would leave they're
frustrated I went in for 20 of those
[ __ ] then I would walk out of
there and just throw the audition in the
garbage as I was walking out cuz I knew
I was never gonna see these people is
the audition like 10 seconds 10 seconds
hi Lee thank you for coming down okay do
you know why yes I do slave for the
camera please
how tall are you how much do you weigh
are you a vegan okay thank you let's do
this stay right there Lee are you ready
hi is this the elevator
that was tremendous thank you for coming
down you just drove over - how long does
that take you two hours to drive back
but those two hours is where you sit in
there and learn how to put that audition
together next time
so it took me like a year of those to
get so [ __ ] frustrated and what then
one night I was high on coke and I
wanted my fault I took out one of those
one line auditions and I go what can I
do this to make it because at this I
want time my objective is time to that
room when you go to those auditions and
you sit outside the audition and you see
people walk in and walk out and there
and there you go who my objective is not
to book this my objective is to sitting
there longer than these fools what do I
have to do to even if I make a mistake
going in there and just to play with her
head
so she calls me how to direct it I'm
still longer than than these fools so I
would take a line and cut it in half and
turn it into to lunch and that's when I
started booking
because would make me hold me in there
longer
and Lingam numbers I would do what
nobody else is doing with that line and
my goal was to sit there as long as
possible
to hold the scene as long as possible so
instead of you running and meeting on
hey stop don't shoot or whatever the
[ __ ] I'll shoot I would see you running
and I go hey come back
stop I'll shoot
I would break it into four breaths even
if she is [ __ ] like it I didn't give
a [ __ ] it kept me in there that was
different than saying that same [ __ ]
line and that's when I started booking
[ __ ]
then I conquered the one line on dishes
okay that's co-star but then you have
now additions that were co-stars that
were two or three lines that was my next
move to get up to that co-star Bowl and
then the next thing is guest star then
you gotta get one of those you gotta
write it out I want to being one guest
our episode and you go in for 30 guest
stars before you book one then the
hardest ones cuz they're the ones that
give the movie stars but then one day
bro you book a guest on you're like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] movie spider-man I had one
line dog well I have one was by the bed
yeah but I flew off the [ __ ] floor I
landed on the couch my hat flew off you
know I gave them nothing but hard that
audition I didn't just go don't move me
whatever the [ __ ] the line was yeah I
said something and then spores and then
said again and then flew [ __ ]
backwards and when I get to him you
gotta go through me I think it was yeah
yeah so even for that I got that [ __ ]
and then I have vows I got taxi and I
got a monologue and I gotta analyze this
and they have a little monologue in the
beginning and then BAM I have to walk
this yard now like I got all these
movies that opened up on me with credits
going through me [ __ ] [ __ ] that I gotta
get out of that thing did you notice
that helped you in stand-up at all
what's it booked more because you're all
of a sudden you're making appearances in
what movies well I'll tell you what
happens and I tell people this that's
very important and a lot of comics look
at me like I'm [ __ ] crazy the most
important thing is to let people know to
send a message is when they see you on
TV that's the bottom line that means
duckets
so that club owned that didn't like you
before now doesn't want to be on the bad
side of you in case you do blow up so
now you will get MC spots in there and
guess what if you're nice and you do a
good job and I recommend you you'll
start [ __ ] feature how important is
if you think to have a manager or an
agent for stand-up okay at my point
where I'm like nine years in now okay
you have to look at what you're making
and you have to be realistic with
yourself what is he gonna make from my
comedy salary
[Music]
how is he gonna make a living off me if
I gave somebody 10 percent of my time a
salary would like what if Joey Diaz gave
me 10 percent of this County salary well
I thought would you even take the time
to call me back you make a 500 club
maybe mm-hmm he gets 50 [ __ ] dollars
worth $50 on the door front then why do
it
so but isn't the idea that he's gonna
get you more work well it took here's
the here's the thing and I just saw it
happened with two two friends of mine
they went with comics that had comics
that were huge and you're sitting there
waiting for something to fall off the
big tree and nothing falls off the big
tree and I'll tell you why because Lee
leaves my number three client I Berkeley
on the road for the weekends for 30 G's
a weekend so D'Agostino what you want me
to do is hang up with will these clothes
and call a club that you them with
featurette a 500 [ __ ] dollars so you
get $50 commission that's how you're
telling me I just closed a deal for
[ __ ] Lee for 24 grand and he gets a
five grand bonus if he sells out and you
want me to call [ __ ] Cottondale comedy
club and [ __ ] cocktail New Jersey and
booked you for a feature act for Louie
the wine frog it's a tough mentality for
a comic they even think yeah he's going
to help me they don't make a few calls
for you and then call you and then go
bro I'm too busy with Lee
so you have to see where you're at
because at the end of the day is again
the envelope yep how much you're gonna
bring to the [ __ ] table
so for Standardization is not really a
point to have a manager in Asia and tell
your someone to sell absolutely and you
get work on your own so you always know
how to get work on your own that's the
most important thing that if the allow I
see a ton of people they'll go bro how
come you go out so much I gotta age it I
don't go out I got an image of the
manager well this is the problem that
you sit home away for the phone to ring
even though you have a manager an agent
you still have to create your own [ __ ]
so they can make the coffee you have to
give them a reason you have to create a
hailstorm so you gotta be doing
something all times a short-film even if
it's for free you're always doing
something a podcast a short film you're
[ __ ] helping your friends write a
[ __ ] on one-man show and you're gonna
co-directed you look at me like Joey
what the [ __ ] does that Duke's and don't
do dick but it lets people know that
you're working it might take it might
somebody who doesn't give you work today
doesn't mean dick that person's gonna
give you work for five years even though
now you've called him 10 times and he
won't return your calls
it's [ __ ] crazy but at the end of the
week it's about money that's the bottom
on it everybody wants to say they have
managers of agents yeah you have some
agents that puts on this and put you out
of that but it all depends on your heat
I've seen a lot of comics in this town
to their slang what manages the too big
for them then they get frustrated two
guys and call me back so he's [ __ ]
Andrew Dice clays managing Hanson's
manager he's gonna call you back to get
your weekend at the Boise Idaho funny
bone I'm happy that you're still doing
it I'm happy he's still putting a little
writing team and if I have dates this
year that I could take young I always
take care of your own a real
up-and-coming like I said me and my
little younger agent were speaking of my
and I've always respected your writing
so let me know what you want this year
you got a book a commercial yeah I want
to start breaking into the acting a
little bit you want to write material
wanna revit irreal I want to keep my at
least four spots a week
I want my podcast to be doing a lot
better Woody's on Tuesday minutes
Tuesday not really anywhere to go on
Tuesday I mean I'll usually go to like
to the main clubs and just have to show
my face in there maybe the one I will go
to the fourth wall it should be open but
I'm definitely open
it's open they started up again on the
29th good day okay we were all over
there today
that's all ooh you rather would leave
say it I have been close over closer for
the holiday yeah when I was here yeah
you go up when you go there yeah yeah
you like it yeah I mean I think I've
gone out there like for three or four
times maybe five times I put up there
before we're gonna
yeah let's go she was correct I like him
but no I'm happy you had time to come on
the show thank you for having me goals
are important and Tommy mm-hmm and a lot
of people don't realize you have to know
what you're going for it's night you're
spending your [ __ ] wheels every year
and you're in the same place you were a
year ago you have to look at the year
later he's okay well my goals is here
and look at them and go look at this I
went for three [ __ ] guest stars but I
got two of them I went for three
commercials buy a tool while I do it I
went to acting class one night a week
and like I said listen wrong everybody
wants to go listen well this guy was
Buffy the Vampire Slayer I think there's
a [ __ ] give me a guy that knows how to
break down acting scene for $90 a month
Tuesday nights from 7:00 to 10:00 I
could care less all you're looking for
is two or three months acting class just
to realize what these guys aren't doing
so now you do that so now you're always
busy as a comic you're working at night
you're dropping off envelopes in the
dates on and what you're doing is it's
like a positive energy [ __ ] magnet
you're creating your own thing is you
you're going to places and dropping off
these envelopes something has to happen
something has to happen and you'll go
drop an envelope off hoping for this
roll this call but you dropped an
envelope off two weeks ago that now
they're cast me you forgot about and now
they call you go Jesus Christ if I were
to sat at home over there I got the
admission
it's it's a hustle and now you cover the
two bases you covered the backdoor and
you still work on the front door thank
you for coming out tonight thank you for
having you door there most the month I'm
mourning it up well don't leave the
shapee eyeballs are as red as your shirt
oh yeah I love it
the [ __ ] kosher ready to [ __ ] these
empty no no that's still good leave
those they don't even touch me don't
even touch that go [ __ ] your fingernails
up
speaking of fingernails let me talk to
you people about something does your
business have any new year resolutions
isn't important isn't important what
every business should consider make your
hiring process more efficient and
effective this year let's zip recruit
out no one has done a better job of
transforming how you find the right
talent then they huh then they have zip
recruit listen if you're in need a great
talent for your business but short on
time you don't have to get lost and the
huge stack of resumes to find your
perfect time you just need the right
tools smaller tools and that's a
reciprocal that comes in why the zipper
could approach your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards with just
one click
then zip recruiter actively looks for
the most qualified candidates and they
invite them to apply they even review
the application to identify the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
that's why zip recruit is different
unlike other job hirings the zip
recruiter doesn't depend on the right
candidates finding you it finds them
no wonder 80 90 80 % of employers who
post on zipper coolant get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
find out today why zip recruiter has
been used by businesses of all sizes and
industries to find the most effective
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now today the church
family can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free free free as I say that free
just go to zipper cool and calm slash
Church CH you are CH that's zipper
cooler dot Tom's last Church one more
time zip recruiter calm slash shirts the
smart way to find someone to hire number
two but listen don't embarrass me but
don't make me not say it it's a new year
you want it you want a date you want to
go on match.com and Christian mingle
that's all nice you got a nice car but
you don't want when you take your pants
off for them to suck your dick they
could smell their [ __ ] by the time
you by the time your buckle your pants
they could smell that rot developing in
your [ __ ] because you need to stop
home and take a shower and wash that
muffler you think it's cute they [ __ ]
leave the house at seven take this two
shits at work and then walk around with
that death that all day why what do you
do is C so uncle Joey's here to help you
out you know why I'm bringing your a
portable bidet
you're like uncle Joey what's that of a
day and spoil them well your stats use
you're attached to right to your toilet
and every time you take a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you press a button hot water hits your
ass and you have to touch it out the
waste toilet paper [ __ ] disgusting
they killed twenty trees for you to wipe
one [ __ ] time those days are done
we're back baby
so the hello pushy calm right now
impressing church you're ten percent off
let me tell you son
they got [ __ ] birthdays of every
color don't match your bathroom decor in
one way or another you understand me
speaking about decor you have decor and
you'll be walking around with a clean
[ __ ] [ __ ] just start the new year
off don't listen
that's number one thing
like keep your muffler clean go to hello
Trisha calm and use code Church and get
10% off your own let me tell you
something you got a 60 day money back
guarantee if something happens listen
I've had mine for two years
please have it for two years if we
haven't breaking him with our fat ass
you won't either hello - she's calm I'll
see your [ __ ] Wednesday night
tip top Magoo ready to rock and roll I
want to wish a lot of luck to the
Agostino hump them any way I can thank
you and my main man the [ __ ]
[ __ ] forgetting the night off
correctly we ate some [ __ ] tremendous
edibles and went deep for you people
tonight on a full moon here in
California yeah it is
stay black we'll see you month Wednesday
I love you [ __ ] don't forget
sorry about the ice houses sold out
Saturday night but we'll see you January
18th Austin Texas [ __ ] what cap city
comedy club get your tickets now before
they [ __ ] go quick cuz I don't hit
him
I'm not going out that much this year so
I don't think that I love I love [ __ ]
Austin you know me I make my [ __ ]
bi-yearly I'm parents a little [ __ ]
there's every other year I'm coming down
a tree that's all you need to know
January 18 ready to [ __ ] rock any
gumbo would [ __ ] Katrina fingernails
in I'll see you [ __ ] then I
have a great [ __ ] in two days and
we'll talk to you Thursday more than
stay black kicked that [ __ ] mule II
[Music]